Alok Mishra, Producer: If you are going to
do this if it's in your heart then you need
to start calling yourself a filmmaker you got to
start calling yourself a producer. I don't care,
faking it until you make it.
Whatever you’ve got to do,
whatever you got to do, but you
need to call yourself a filmmaker.
Film Courage: Your plan was to go into medicine?
Alok: Yes, my father's plan for me. Indian
people, like I'm Indian, are doctors, lawyers,
engineers usually and stuff. My dad was a
doctor and he had one son (myself) that was
intellectually stimulated by medicine and so
he thought “you should be a doctor” I got up
into doing a masters in neurobo [neurobiology]
and doing well enough on the MCAT to be able
to go to school and I just told him I don't
want to do this. I wanted to do film instead.
Film Courage: When you told
him I don't want to do this,
did you take any new measures to get yourself into
film after that or it was a weaning off process?
Alok: I told him and he was like “Well if
you're going to do it, you’ve got like two
years to figure it out right just do it so I got
an internship I wanted to do development I wanted
to do producing so I got an internship with a guy
named David Friendley who worked on the Fox side
had a three picture deal and he did such movies
as Big Mama's House or Dr. Dolittle the Eddie
Murphy one and I cut my teeth being an intern
there and then got to be an assistant and then
discovered the amazing world of market research
for film which I then started doing for 18 years
years are testing movies for a living what are
your thoughts on balancing a day job and being
an artist I mean everyone's got to eat right
like that's that's the that's the that's the
toughest thing I mean I think that if you have to
have a day job I think that you have to do some
work for your art every day if it's 10 minutes
great if it's an hour be better if it's an hour
then that's that's the best idea you have to
sort of like keep it's hard because like you
get bogged down in your day job and you don't
think about those times you're going to be on
set and like and and when you get to set like how
important that is like you got to move everything
out of your head in the terms of that day job
this is the real job that you're trying to do
so many people have this impostor syndrome where
they're like they don't want to call themselves
like filmmakers but that's what you are if you
are going to do this if it's in your heart then
you need to start calling yourself a filmmaker you
got to start calling yourself a producer I don't
care faking it until you make it whatever you got
to do whatever you got to do but you need to call
yourself a filmmaker because that's if that's in
your heart and that's what you want to do then
that's what you need to do and you need to work on
it every day for at least an hour at least an hour
i' hope some days are worse than others I get that
too but like if you really do want to succeed you
have to be persistent you always hear about like
you have these friends that are not successful and
they're doing their day jobs and they're also
doing like trying to find this dream when you
find like one out of 10 friends actually succeeds
and you're like why did that friend succeed versus
like the other friends that are sitting around
La and think they're actors but they never go
on auditions or whatever it is right that person
works really hard and they're prepared and I'm
not going to say this fakakta like opportunity
means whatever it is like you if you've worked
and put the hours in and you have something really
unique then it's going to be seen one day and you
have to make sure that you're persistent you
have to like this is what you do this is my
job this is this I I I earn money over here for
my living expenses but this is my job over here
that's what you have to think about it I think
when your dad said two years you had left this
master's program is it and your dad said 2 years
did you did you feel that this immense pressure
or did you feel immense freedom I knew in my head
whatever he told me I was never going back that's
what I knew like I mean I think the thing of it
for me was that I felt freedom for sure I felt
like a big weight had been lifted that's true too
I mean film is not easier than medicine but like
it's different for sure I just knew for me I was
never going back there and I would do anything I
would have to do to try to be successful and in
some part of the industry to to show my father
that like I can make a living I'm happy I don't
want to do that anymore so let me do this and I
did it was full market research and so forth and
that was fine and my dad would always kid me like
we can still get you in a Mexico in the Caribbean
I was like no Dad I'm happy doing what I'm doing
now and at the end of the day I was I was very
happy my my dad passed this share and I was very
happy that he actually got to see come to set see
what we were doing filming the movie and then once
we got to number one on Netflix he really did
like he was just like my son's a producer like
he actually was just like yeah it was nice that's
great what are some things that stopped you from
making that leap in the very beginning from
having a day job to film making look I think
that you everyone's plagued by self-doubt they're
just like ah is this the right script no is this
the right script is this the right script well I
don't want to I don't want to start unless it's
going to be perfect it's never going to be perfect
okay it's never going to be perfect you're never
going to have enough money you're never going to
have enough time you're never going to have to
have it's never there never a perfect situation
I think at some point you sorry my excuse my
language just say [“fudge it”] it and I'm gonna
like now I'm going to do this and you have a team
around you right that's the other thing too like
unless I had had like my producing partner Shane
Vorster we have a company called Malevolent Films
he also did market research for film right we both
kind of were cut from the same cloth and we found
this 1BR script we found many scripts but we found
1BR in particular we were like oh my gosh this
is a great script we need to like sit and meet
with these guys and we met with David Marmor who's
an amazing writer writer director he never done a
feature before but we were like Hey we're first
time producers your first time writer director
what could go wrong a lot but we we met with him
we liked Tim he was one part of the puzzle right
we had the script we had the director who we
thought would be like the guy that could bring
it home and we had other producers that we kind of
aligned with who were more experienced producers
who were like this can be real we can go and
do this thing we just need to have the money
and that's obviously a big thing that SS people
too is having the money and we thought we went
all over the place looking for money we didn't
find any money because no one wants to trust a
first-time producer and firsttime writer director
that's that's like low on people's list of wanting
to trust so we decided to bet on ourselves like
shanee put some money in I mortgage an already
paid off house and even the direct writer director
David Marmor put in a line share the money too
equal on footing to all of us in fact he bet
on himself at the end of the day so like I said
you're never going to have the time you're never
going to have the money you're never going to have
everything be perfect but when you have at least
some of the pieces and you have now confidence a
little bit confidence sometimes has to build like
you're gonna be there's like a lot of self-doubt
but if you can find the confidence and have the
team around you that has the confidence too then
you can go for for and make it and you might as
well because no one's getting any younger was
going to say that and who was the first one to put
money in Shane and I we're we're first funding it
and then we were like okay we're going to we shot
for 17 days initially sorry 15 days initially in
December 2017 and then we needed to do re-shoot
for it and so at that point our writer director
David Marmor helped out for that and he also
helped out because he wanted set instead of
instead of like real locations stuff so so the two
of you both took that leap together yes yeah yeah.